i thought it would be great
if i could tell an old story
that was from years ago that never made
it to a one-hour special
and the cool part about this story is
that it it now has a different ending
the story is called
the gift basket
some of you know it
some of you don't know it but after this
you're never gonna forget it
all you have to know about this story is
that all the people involved have always
been and will continue to be friends
that being said
martin and i
all the good ones start like that
martine and i
are scheduled to perform in northern
california usually we fly but this
particular day i was having a problem
with southwest airlines they wanted me
to pay for an extra seat for someone who
wasn't traveling with me
take your time you'll figure it out
anyway i tell martin i'm not paying for
an
[Applause]
seeing billboards off the side of the
freeway that said performing this
weekend at the radisson hotel directly
from bet's comic view and showtime at
the apollo comedian g riley and i look
at martina go oh shoot she's in town and
martin goes yeah i haven't seen g in
years so we're like let's stop by the
hotel and say hi so we pull into the
parking lot
[Music]
we walk in i tell martin he doesn't know
we're here
i'm gonna crank call his room because
what are you gonna say i said i'm gonna
tell him that i'm the front desk and
that he just received a gift basket
what's so funny about a gift basket i
said
i'm gonna describe it over the phone and
i'm gonna make all the items that are in
this imaginary basket become items that
stereotypically a black person might
like
but you're crazy i said i'll tell you
what we got two hours to kill how about
this how about we go to the supermarket
and we make an actual racist gift basket
and we'll have it delivered and we'll
wait outside to see what happens i said
are you down
we go to a store and we start to design
the sickest practical joke ever i get a
shopping cart and i'm like all right we
need a basket so i find one i take out
the grass the plastic eggs and the
chocolate rabbits and we start hitting
the aisles
first item i grab is a fried chicken
about that big okay
see how quick that laugh was
[Laughter]
there's a few black people in here like
mother this better be funny
it's hysterical let me just finish the
story and then you could judge me in the
parking lot so anyway then martin hands
me a miniature watermelon and i put it
next to the fried chicken
here's where it gets interesting
employees of the store find out what
we're doing and they start volunteering
to help us finish the basket
half of the employees were black which
made it so much more accurate
aisle after aisle one guy was stalking a
shelf he was an older white guy and
we're like sir can you help us what do
you need my buddy martin and i are
trying to make this messed up racist
gift basket for our black friend as a
practical joke can you think of
something we can put in there without
even blinking an eye the guy was like ah
you gotta have kool-aid
it's at the end of the aisle on the
right malt liquors in excel over in the
back of the store in the freezer section
it's on sale two for one by the time we
get to the register all these different
employees plus us came up with the
basket that had fried chicken watermelon
kool-aid grape soda barbecue potato
chips sunflower seeds an ebony magazine
a chris rock dvd called bigger and
blacker magnum condoms newport
cigarettes a rack of ribs the recipe for
cornbread it was getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger
icing on the cake we find a greeting
card that's on clearance from halloween
and it has a picture of three ghosts on
the cover wearing sheets
i tear off the half that says happy
halloween and on the back of the card i
write welcome to fresno love the chamber
of commerce
and we stick it to the basket we made it
all nice and pretty and we haul ass to
the hotel
we pull up
we walk in the basket is hot as hell so
i'm racing in
i get inside and i put it on the counter
as fast as i can bro it's too perfect
there's a black girl behind the front
desk
as soon as i put the basket down i hear
is that chicken
oh let me say hold on
what is it let me explain my name is
gabriel this is martin we're a couple of
comedians and we're about to play a
really crazy practical joke on a friend
of ours who's staying here tonight by
the name of g riley who's also a
comedian
i don't want to sound the signs on a
free what yeah the one that's on the
signs on the freeway so as a practical
joke we went to the store and we made
this messed up racist gift basket that's
that's why you can smell fried chicken
and she was like
you need jesus that's a true name
kiki girl you better hang up that phone
you ain't gonna believe what i'm looking
at over here girl
listen we think it would be hysterical
if we could have you deliver the basket
for us
she lost it oh the hell you didn't
i know you didn't just ask me to take
that to a black man you are out your
damn mind oh lord love
give me the strength
to not kill this big ass mexican over
here lord
okay look here nacho libre i don't care
who you are i am not doing it hell no
i'll give you 50 bucks where that
[ __ ]
we follow her to the hotel room she
knocks on the door martine and i hide by
the elevator on the floor she knocks
she opens the door sees a beautiful
black woman standing there with a gift
basket this is for you baby he says
thank you closes the door
she walks away and she sees us on the
ground hiding right and she's like y'all
still going to hell
we get up and we walk over to the door
we put our ear listen
this is what we hear
inside
chicken
he's getting excited over every single
item he's pulling out of the basket he
gets to the greeting card what can the
fresno love the chamber of commerce hell
yeah then we feel him flipping the card
over because his voice changed he's like
oh yeah man this is what the [ __ ]
outside the door we heard racist
bastards
when we heard racist bastards we lost it
housekeeping is freaking out
we're laughing we're crying we got
boogers coming out we can't take it
anymore we knock on the door
he yells who is it too easy chamber of
commerce
he rushes the door i put my finger on
the peephole so he can't see who it is
right the knob starts to jiggle then the
door explodes open and he's like what
and he sees us and he's like
what's up g man y'all give a brother
heart attack
did you like your basket man that was
messed up did you like it man
i love all that [ __ ]
so i get a letter in the mail from my
old high school and it's like you know
time for the reunion my girlfriend saw
the letter she's like oh your reunion i
go yeah i'm a reunion when is it when
are we going um
actually i was i was gonna take my
friend tony because you know we went to
high school together he's my best friend
since high school so i was gonna take
tony
you're gonna take tony instead of me
that's what's gonna happen how you're
gonna take tony instead of me your
girlfriend you're gonna take tony no
it's okay
it's okay you take tony okay and i hope
you have a great time
oh thanks i knew you'd understand baby
don't ask too many questions you know
so my buddy tony now we go to a high
school reunion we get there early too
early there's nobody in the banquet hall
so we go upstairs to the bar area we're
watching a basketball game everything is
cool until some guy recognized me
hey you're the comedian what's up dude
dude funny bro let me buy you a shot
actually man um
i have my reunion right now and and i
don't want to show up drunk
oh
i see how it is bro
you're too good huh that's what that's
what it is huh excuse me george lopez
let's do the stupid shot all right
bartender shot so he freaking makes a
double and we freaking cling cling and
slam that i'm like oh
oh thank you man thank you let's do
another one
hey i'm okay thank you see how it is
paul rodriguez
let's do another shot
and he kept this pattern going he must
have had like seven comedians behind his
freaking wallet you know one after
another i got so drunk i could i was
that level of drunk where you can't even
walk straight you got to look at the
ground to navigate you know you just
kind of
i get to the reunion there's a lady at a
table and she's got stickers on the
table that say hello my name is and then
with a sharpie you write your name i was
so drunk i couldn't even write gabriel i
wrote flaco
which is spanish for skinny so you know
i freaking write that stick it on and we
walk in
the party's going on you know
[Music]
i'm trying to find a table my buddy tony
took off i couldn't find him i'm sitting
there i'm like oh my god
all of a sudden the lights come up and
the class president is holding the
microphone
hello everyone welcome to the wilson
high school class reunion let's just cut
to the chase find out what everyone's
been up to and keep the party rocking
so she pulls out a list who's done this
who's done that who has the most
children some girl in the back seven
everybody's like
now you remember okay
all right
she keeps going down the list who's in
this who's done that who who's been on
television everybody at my table who
wasn't talking to me before you know
they weren't talking to me before now
they're like
right here right here right here
[Music]
sure enough here comes the girl oh we
have a celebrity over here come on say
something get up here flake oh come on
flacco get up here
okay oh come on get up here are you too
good or what so i got mad and i jumped
up i'm not too good
um
everybody my name is gabriel okay
gabriel
iglesias
um i don't want to say a whole lot right
now because i've been drinking and i
don't want to say nothing stupid
it's really nice to be here with
everybody
i see two girls here tonight
two
who when i was in the 12th grade
i asked out to the prom
and they said no
well you know what it's okay it's up let
me go
it's okay you know what it's okay
because like she said i've been on tv
and you two girls who said no
you got fat
one of them yells out you're fat too i
know i'm fat but i was fat in high
school
i kept my figure why couldn't you
do
[Music]
i took a road trip about a year ago
after i got rid of the beetle in the suv
took a road trip from l.a to phoenix to
go perform at this club
let me tell you who's in the car i'm
driving i got my buddy armando riding a
shotgun he's another fluffy guy we call
him sexy [ __ ]
i don't call him that his wife calls him
that he's a sexy [ __ ] anyway
the back seat i got my friend martin
next to him is my friend felipe so we
take off
we're on the 10th freeway we're passing
all these indian casinos
sorry we're stupid like that anyway
all of a sudden all these cars start
passing me around
i'm getting annoyed because i'm driving
i said next car that tries to pass me
i'm not gonna let him so i'm looking in
the rearview mirror waiting looking
waiting waiting and i see a silver dot
the silver dot turned out to be a little
car with two hoochies in it right
i said some of you guys are going how do
you know they're hoochies because my
friend martine was in the back seat
going i feel a disturbance in the force
[Music]
they tried to go around and i cut them
off
i'm having fun they're back there
whatever
my friend is in the back seat yelling at
me
what are you doing i go dude don't worry
i'm having fun gary you're gonna get
pulled over dude i'm okay it's cool
we're arguing going back and forth i'm
not paying attention i don't see a
california highway patrol officer
creeping up on us
all of a sudden i hear
i look at the speedometer 102.
oh i freaked out
[Music]
the little car that was behind me with
the two hoochies they got pulled over
because they were going just as fast you
know
i'm in the front seat of my car freaking
out oh my god oh my god
i'm on the verge of tears
from the back seat i hear my friend full
what are you crying for
what are you crying for pho you're not
the one with weed in his pocket are you
[Applause]
you have drugs in the car
i told you to slow down didn't i
but no
pikachu knows everything
shoot everybody roll down your window
i hurt the car bundle fart do something
man
the car box over the window looks in
sees my face recognizes me from tv right
he's like hey
i know you
you're a comedian
yeah you're that guy from comedy central
you're the guy that does that joke about
his friend at a hotel in your crank
column and you call him a dirty mexican
and then you go but it was funny huh oh
i love that joke that one and when you
go chocolate cake oh i love it joe
i hate to do this to you but we got two
cars involved i need your license and
registration okay here you go here you
go so he takes my info goes back to the
car with the two girls in it ryan the
whole time he's back there i tell
everybody in the car check it out he
just recognized me from tv
maybe if we have some fun with him crack
some jokes maybe he won't take the car
i don't care if i get a ticket but as
long as he doesn't take the car mondo be
silly crack a joke my team be funny
thank you what fool shut the hell up
so the cow comes back to the car what
the hell were you doing out there before
i could think of something funny to say
from the back seat i hear oh he was
testing the suspension
oh my god this pothead's gonna get me
arrested
officer i'm sorry that's the guy from
the special that's the guy who says but
it was funny huh he's just trying to get
me in trouble i'm really sorry
whatever so he goes back to a squad car
with my driver's license and he's
swiping it in a computer the whole time
he's doing that he's being yelled at
from the back seat of my car
hey officer thank god you have a
computer last week we got stuffed in
mexico that fool had a rolodex
the cop starts dying
i go oh my god i'm going we got them
going i tell my buddy mundo give me my
cds i take out my bad boys 2 soundtrack
and i pop it in track 3 is the theme
song to cops i tell my friend tell me
when the cop starts walking okay well
here he comes i cranked that song as
loud as i could
[Music]
bad boys why aren't you gone while
you're gone what you gonna
[Music]
now the cop is walking to the beach
[Music]
[Applause]
even better than that the two hoochies
in the car can hear the music and
they're freaking out they're like oh my
god we're gonna be on tv
the cop goes to the girls gives them a
ticket lets them go
looks at our car and at this point we're
like halfway through the song right
we're like
please not give it nobody
[Laughter]
[Music]
the cop is in the middle of the freeway
dying
he walks over the window and he's like
shut it off
yes sir
hands me my license and the registration
and he tells me gabriel
i want you to do me a big favor i want
you to keep this tank
under a hundred you think you can do
that
do that for me keep on doing what you do
and you have yourself a nice day
that's it no ticket
no ticket
i don't know what possessed me to look
at this man and go why
how come the girls got a ticket
and he tells me the coolest thing he
says because they couldn't make me laugh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't understand gabriel i've been
on the force now for 26 years this is
hands down the funniest damn traffic
stop i've ever been a part of do you
have any idea how hard it is to give two
[ __ ] a ticket while listening to
cops i damn near pissed myself i was
laughing so hard
this is going in the books is one of the
funniest things ever happened to police
officer i swear to god the only story
better than this one is a buddy of mine
pulled over some fat guy that gave him
donuts
[Applause]
so he starts walking away right and just
as i'm about to start the car
so does that mean i can keep my weed
i turn around the yellow my friend too
late the cop is out the window you want
to run that by me again sean
you heard what i said fool
oh you think this is a big joke don't
you
you think that just cause i gave your
buddy here a break i know who he is i
like what he does i don't know you i
don't like you step out of the car
i turn around and my friend's like oh
i am so scared
and the cop pulls out his gun
i'm freaking out i'm like oh my god back
seat
[Music]
i am so scared fool he's good he is good
then he points it at him
the look on my friend's face oh
priceless
hey i'm serious
the cop was like
nah
but that was funny huh
i love you bakersfield thank you